I am an astrophysicist I research
stellar explosions across the universe
but I have a flaw I'm Restless and I get
bored easily and although as an
astrophysicist I have the incredible
opportunity to study the entire universe
the star of doing only that always done
makes me feel caged and limited well if
my issues with keeping attention and
getting bored were not a flood Oh what
if I could turn them into an on-set an
astrophysicists cannot touch or interact
with the things that she studies no way
to explore the star in a lab to figure
out why or how I blew up just pictures
and movies of the sky everything we know
about the universe from the Big Bang the
originator space and time to the
formation and evolution of stars and
galaxies to the structure of our own
solar system we figured out studying
images on the sky and to study a system
as complex as the entire universe
astrophysicists are experts at
extracting simple models and solutions
from large and complex datasets so what
else can I do with these expertise well
if we turn the camera around towards us
at the urban observatory that is exactly
what we're doing
Greg Dobler also an astrophysicist and
my husband created the first urban
observatory a New York University in
2013 and I joined in 2015 here are some
of the things that we do we take
pictures of the city at night and study
city lights like stars by studying how
light changes over time and the color of
astronomical lights I gain insight about
the nature of exploding stars by
studying city lights the same way we can
measure and predict how much energy the
city needs and consumes and help build a
resilient grid that will support the
needs of growing urban environments in
day time images we capture plumes of
pollution 75% of greenhouse gases in
your
Ceri come from a building like this from
burning oil for heat you can measure
pollution with air quality sensors but
imagine putting a sensor on each new
york city building reading in data from
a million monitors imagine the cost with
the team of NYU students who built a
mathematical model a neural network that
can detect and track these flumes over
the New York City skyline we can
classify them harmless steam plumes
white and evanescent polluting
smokestacks dark and persistent and
provide policymakers with map of
neighborhood pollution this
cross-disciplinary projects created
transformational solutions but the data
analysis methodologies we use in
astrophysics can be applied to all sorts
of data not just images we were asked to
help a California District Attorney
understand prosecutorial delays in their
jurisdiction there are people on
probation or sitting in jail awaiting
for trial sometimes for years they
wanted to know what kind of cases
dragged on and had a massive dataset to
explore to understand it but didn't have
the expertise or the instruments in
their office to do so and that's where
we came in I work with my colleague
public policy professor Angela Hawkins
and our team first created a visual
dashboard for DA's to see and better
understand the prosecution process but
also we ourselves analyze their data
looking to see if the duration of the
process suffer from social inequalities
in their jurisdiction we did so using
methods that I would use to classify
thousands of stellar explosions apply to
thousands of court cases and in doing so
we built a model that can be applied to
other jurisdictions who are willing to
explore their biases
these collaborations between domain
experts and astrophysicists created
transformational solutions to help
improve people's quality of life but it
is a two-way Road I bring my
astrophysics background to urban science
and I bring what I learn in urban
science back to astrophysics light
echoes the reflections of stellar
explosions on two
interstellar dust in our images these
reflections appears as white evanescent
moving features just like plumes
I am adapting the same models that had
plumes in city images to detect light
echoes in images of the sky by exploring
the things the interest and excitement
reaching outside of my domain I did term
I restlessness into an asset we you all
have a unique perspective the can
January new insight and lead to new
unexpected transformational solutions
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]